[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راوي القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزوايا هو من
جميع جوانبه
اردوغان يضم الى سيغ للولايات المنكوبه
وهاتاي تعلق عمليه الانقاذ للغد والمعارضه
ترتب اوراقها
المتحده تناشد لمضاعفه التبرعات لسوريا
وتؤكد ان مشرد الزلزال يفتقرون للماوى
والمياه النظيفه
ذخائري لحساب اوكرانيا وامريكا اللاتينيه
ترفض طلبه واشنطن لتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
حملتها نحو البيت الابيض بالتاكيد على
مواجهه الاعداء في روسيا والصين وايراننا
في سوريا يتواصل دخول المساعدات لاغاثه
منكوب الزلزال لكنها ما تزال بعيده عن
تلبيه الاحتياجات لذلك تطالب الامم
المتحده بمضاعفه التبرعات وتحذر من الوضع
الكارثي هناك اما في تركيا فما تزال
الحكومه تؤكد انها ستواصل عمليه الانقاذ
لكن الاخبار الاتيه من هاتاي تقول العكس
ففرق الانقاذ علقت عملها الى الغدي بسبب
نقص الكوادر سباق مع الزمن لانتشال
الناجين قاسم لكن البرد والاجهاد ليس اقل
قسوه كذلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا عمري
انا جنبك والله
يا شباب
يلا الله اكبر
شباب اعطونا حرام نغطيه عندك
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من اليمن محمود شكر مفدى
العربيه اهلا بك محمود
يعني يبدو انك تتواجد في احد مراكز
الايواء
نقول لنا الصوره نعم
نعم بطبيعه الحال هي قصه من نوع اخر
ولكنها ترتبط ارتباطا وثيقا بالتداعيات
التي حصلت ما بعد الزلزال هذا المكان الذي
نتواجد به الان هو في الاساس مطعم للجامعه
في المدينه ولكنه تحول في الايام الاولى
الى مركز كبير
لعمليه احتواء الذين خرجوا من منازلهم
ولكن بعد عشره ايام ايضا تحول جزء منه كما
نرى في هذه الصور الى مكان للمبيت
للعائلات ان كانت للعائلات السوريه او
ايضا للتركيه نشاهد هذه العائله الان من
الام وايضا بنتها وايضا هذه البنت الصغيره
هي عائله باكملها تجلس في هذا المكان منذ
اربعه الى خمسه ايام هي بطبيعه الحال
تسال او تطالب ان يكون لها عمليه انتقال
هذا المكان الى مكان اخر بالتوازي الحكومه
التركيه هي تقوم باقامه مخيمات ولكن هذه
المخيمات حتى هذه الساعه لم تكتمل اذا
اخذنا ايضا هنا الصوره من هذه الجهه سنذهب
ايضا الى هذا الرجل الذي هو لاجئ السوري
ويظهر انه يصلي العشاء في هذا التوقيت
ايضا هو اخبرني الى انه عائلته منذ ايام
عديده يبيتون في هذه الزاويه هنا لكل
زاويه حكايه ولكل زاويه عائله ولكل عائله
منطقه
العام هو من حمص مثلا هذه مكانه هذه عائله
ثانيه كرديه هي من منطقه اخرى هذه مكانها
هذه عائله ايضا من منطقه اخرى من الداخل
السوري ايضا لها مكانها اذا ذهبنا ايضا
بالت
[موسيقى]
اول شيء بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
نسال الله السلامه للشعب التركي والسوري
والله يشفي الجرحى ويرحم الشهداء
نحن اول زلزال كنت نايم اما ابوي
يا الله اطلعوا لبرا في زلزال انا طلعت
لبره وهيك عم ترج الارض والبنات عم توقع
ونحن خفنا كتير انتوا لبيتكم بنايه او
طابق طابق
طابقين شو صار معك ساعتها هربتوا نعم
طلعنا بالبيت بسرعه ابوي قال لي اهلك
راحوا اخواتك وامك راحوا
يعني لوين راحوا عربوا
بس الحمد لله شفناهم طلعوا من البيت
وفرحنا وبعدين رحنا على الشارع رحنا تحت
المطر
والدتك هون لحظه شوي والدتك
وشقيقتك وعندك والدك وهذا الشاب الصغير
مين هيدا
هذا شو اسمه
شو يا مصطفى انت هربت من الزلزال
الزلزال خبرني لشوف
ايه وين كنت
وخايف هلا او خلاص ماشي بدك تخاف
هون شو عم تعمل
مبسوط قاعد هون بالمحل او وين بدك البيت
او وين احلاهم او البيت
هون احلى
انا عم تلعب وعم تاكل وكل شي
طيب هلا بس يقولوا لك انه في زلزال بتخاف
او خلاص ما شو بدك تخاف
لا طلع على الكاميرا
شفتها
وهلا شو بدك قل لي شو بدك اطلب مني شي
لحتى انه انا مثلا اجيب لك اياه انت شو
حابب لحتى اجيب لك
اللي ما تستحي شو بدك
[موسيقى]
بدك بيت بدك بيت بكره بكره بدك بيت او انه
بدك تروح على المخيم بعدين بنروح على
البيت شو رايك
شو قل لي
بيت خلص اوكي بدها بيت يلا بدنا نعمل على
البيت
نعم عزيزتي هذا هي المشاهد هذا هو الوضع
هذه هي الحاله الماساويه كما تشاهدين هي
تترجم نفسها بنفسها ما في داعي نحن
نترجمها ولا في داعي نحن ننقدها هي تتحدث
عن نفسها بنفسها لذلك ساتركها على على
تجري كما على بركه الله شكرا جزيلا لك
محمود شكر موفد العربيه من اديمان شكرا
رصدت كاميرا العربيه جانبا من حركه مرور
بعض المساعدات الامميه التي دخلت من معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي الى سوريا حيث دخلت 22
شاحنه محمله بالمساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه
من الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
وانضم الي من شمال ادلب الصحفي مسلم السيد
عيسى وايضا
اذا فقط السيد مسلم اهلا بك من جديد يعني
هل ترى
اي تحسن باوضاع النازحين السوريين بمناطق
ادلب والمناطق المتضرره لانه هناك حديث
بانه في مناطق لم تصلها اي مساعدات امميه
حتى الان
حتى
[موسيقى]
اللحظه
مقترن بدخول المساعدات عبر المعابر وايضا
مقترن بالموافقات وعبور هذه المساعدات
وتفريغها والى اخرها حتى تصل الى
مستفيديها كما يعني
المنظمات الانسانيه قالت ان المساعدات
التي وصلت وهي قرابه المئتين شاحنه محمله
بالمواد الاغاثيه ان اتحدث عن العشره ايام
الاولى من هذه الكارثه تقريبا ما احصيناه
هو 200 شاحنه ووصلت عبر جميع المعابر
وجميع خطوط التماس هذه الشاحنات لا يمكن
ان تغطي على اقصى تقدير 10 الى اثنين 12
وصلت مسلم يعني على اي مناطق
نعم يعني هذه الشاحنات لو ندخل بالتفاصيل
اكثر دخلت عبر ثلاث معابر باب الهواء باب
السلامه وايضا معبر الحمام حتى اللحظه لم
نسجل دخول مساعدات عبر معبر الراعي وهو
الذي اعلن انه جاهز لاستقبال المساعدات
وبالتالي هذه الثلاث معابر قيمه بشكل
رئيسي تدخل عبرها هذه الشاحنات
وهذه يعني تدخل فقط من عموم المناطق ومن
عموم الدول لكن المساعدات الامميه التابعه
للامم المتحده تدخل فقط عبر باب الهوى وهو
المصرح له بالدخول للمساعدات التابعه
للامم المتحده عبر قرار مجلس مجلس الامن
الاخير فبالتالي يعني عموم المساعده التي
دخلت هي تقريبا 110 الى 115 شاحنه لكن
بالمقابل هناك نقطه جدا مهمه عبر الحاله
الشعبيه والحاله الداخليه يعني وصلت اليوم
من المناطق الشرقيه لسوريا وعبر
اهل الخير في دير الزور
الشعبيه والاهليه 75 شاحنه وبالتالي
تقريبا هي توازي كل ما دخل عبر الحدود الى
المناطق المتضرره يعني نتحدث عن تقارب بين
المساعدات التي جمعها السوريون لانفسهم
وبين المساعدات التي وصلت عبر الحدود هذه
الحاله يعني خلقت جوا جديدا هنا في الداخل
السوري من التعاضد والتكاتف الداخلي
والشعبي بين سكان المنطقه على الشق او في
نفس السياق يعني هذه المساعدات بدات فعلا
توزيعها المساعده او المؤسسات الانسانيه
المحليه على مراكز الايواء المساجد
المدارس وكل الاماكن المفتوحه اود ان يعني
نفوت شوي بالتفاصيل يقال وشهد بكثير من
الفيديوهات مثلا عفرين لم يصلها اي
مساعدات يعني الناس يبيتون في العراء من
دون طعام من دون خيمه حتى يعني هؤلاء كيف
لم تصلهم ان كان مساعدات امميه ام من
الداخل السوري يعني من يهتم بهؤلاء
يعني كما ذكرت اولا لان النسبه ضئيله يعني
كل ما تم ادخاله لا يغطي بحسب المؤسسات
الانسانيه هنا خمسه عشر بالمئه من دائره
الاحتياجات التي حددتها المنظمات هنا
العامله في الداخل وبالتالي من المتوقع ان
تكون هناك عشرات المدن المتضرره لن تصلها
المساعدات على اقل تقدير في الاسبوع
الثاني او في العشره ايام الثانيه من هذه
الكارثه بحسب توقعاتي اولا اعداد ضئيله
ثانيا لان المساعدات التي تدخل عبر معبر
عفرين او جنديرس تدخل مباشره الى بلده
جنديرس وما حولها وهي التي يعني كانت
الاكثر تضررا في هذه الازمه وتنتهي يتم
توزيعها وتنتهي هذه المساعدات لانها
الاولى في هذه الكلمه ماذا تحتوي تلك
المساعدات وهل اخذت بعين الاعتبار القطاع
الطبي يعني هل المساعدات ايضا فيها شيء
يفيد المستشفيات التي اصلا تعاني من الحرب
يعني الحاله التي رصدناها هو وصول بعض
الشاحنات تقريبا ما مجموعه خمس شاحنات
فيها مواد طبيه وايضا مولدات كهربائيه
وبعض الاجهزه الطبيه التي تم توزيعها على
المستشفيات في المناطق المتضرره لان المدن
التي او القرى التي تضررت فيها مستشفيات
يعني طوارئ فقط وليس فيها مستشفيات ضخمه
هذه المستشفيات تم تدميرها بشكل كامل
وبالتالي تم انتقال الكوادر الطبيه الى
مستشفيات اخرى لاستمرار العمل وكما ذكرت
هي تقريبا خمسه شاحنات تم توزيعها على
المستشفيات على شق الاخر من المساعدات
الانسانيه هناك الكثير من التنوع فيما وصل
من مواد غذائيه وسلل وايضا وجبات طعام
ساخنه وغيرها من المطابخ الميدانيه
والخيام لكن يعني هناك نقطه مهمه لاحظتها
ورصتها عبر تواصل مع الناس والسكان الذين
نزحوا انهم قالوا بشكل مباشر لا نريد
البقاء في هذه الماوي المؤقته لاننا يعني
مللنا من النزوح نتحدث نحن هنا عن مئات
والاف العوائل على الاقل نزحت ثلاث او
اربع مرات خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه نتيجه
القصف المتكرر واجبارهم على تهجيرهم
وبالتالي هم ملوا حركات النزوح يعني باتوا
تماما بلا اي موارد ماليه ولجديه الان
لبيت ياويهم
بالدرجه الاولى شكرا جزيلا لك من شمال
ادلب الصحفي مسلم السيد عيسى
وينضم الينا من شمال حلب الصحفي احمد ابو
لؤي اهلا بك سيد احمد كنت اسال ضيفنا مسلم
عن الوضع
بريف عفرين بالعديد من مناطق حلب المتضرره
هل حال يعني الناجين المتضررين كيف هو هل
هو افضل حالا من الايام السابقه بعد
المساعدات التي وصلت ان كانت وصلت
هل تسمعني سيد احمد عبر الهاتف
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
شكرا جزيلا لك بكل الاحوال سيد احمد ابو
لؤي
[موسيقى]
زلزال تركيا اربك المشهد السياسي في
البلاد مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في مايو المقبل الاثنين
الماضي كان من المفترض ان تتفق فيه
المعارضه السياسيه باطيافها على مرشح موحد
لها ليقف في مواجهه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الا ان الزلزال اجل هذا الاجتماع
مصادر في الحزب الحاكم والمعارضه بدات
الترويج عن انباء ان الرئيس اردوغان سيؤجل
الانتخابات في اعقاب الكارثه التي شهدتها
تركيا الاسبوع الماضي صحيفه احوال التركيه
قالت ان المعارضه ستحاول الاستفاده من
الغضب الشعبي بسبب الدمار الذي لحق بتركيا
جراء الزلزال دون الظهور بصوره السعيد
للحصول على مكاسب سياسيه من الماسد حتى
الان يعتبر كمالك لتشدار اوغلو هو ابرز
المرشحين وهو رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
طبعا سيواجه اردوغان الا ان المعارضه
منقسمه لازلت على اسم المرشح ويعتبر
ويعتبر خبراء فعليا ان انتخابات مايو باتت
غير وارده لكنها قد تجرى في يونيو وهو اخر
موعد لاجراءها وفق الدستور اما اذا اقتضى
الامر تاجيرا لموعد ابعد فسيكون على
اردوغان الحصول على غالبيه الثلثين في
البرلمان وهو رقم ليس بجعبه الرئيس
وحلفائه ما يعني انه سيلجا الى المعارضه
للموافقه على تاجيل الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
حسب العداله والتنميه الحاكم في تركيا دفع
تشريع العفو المتعلق بالتطوير العقاري قبل
انتخابات عام 2018 في خطوه اتخذت حينها
لكسب اصوات الناخبين بحسب المعارضه
التركيه بشكل عام هذا التشريع ليس فريدا
في نوعه اذ كان اول تشريع من هذا النوع
دخل حيز التنفيذ عام
ودفعت به حكومات متلاحقه في محاوله لكسب
التاييد اما القانون الاخير لعام 2018 فقد
شمل مئات الالاف من المطورين وملاك
العقارات والمقاولين بحسب وزاره البيئه
وبعد بدء تنفيذ القانون حذر اتحاد غرف
المهندسين والمعماريين في انقره من ان
العفو هذا سيعرض حياه مليونين و700 الف
شخص للخطر لاقامتهم في مباني مشيده بشكل
رديء
ومن انقره ينضم الينا السيد بركات قار
المحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد بركات يعني
كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وما خلفه من
دمار على البشر والحجر فعليا من الذي
سيستفيد منه في القادم من الايام اذا
اجريت الانتخابات التركيه في موعدها
مساء الخير اولا عزيزي الكريم ان هذه
الزلزال طبعا زلزال هو طبيعي كالاحداث
الزلزاليه
والفيضانات والاعصار ويعني احدى منهم يعني
لذلك الان للاسف الشديد لم يكن هناك اي
فرق واتخاذ اي قرارات صارمه على الاقل
تتميز عن
الزلازل اللي عشناها
والامور والماساه اللي عشناها في السابق
هذا شيء كان مهم جدا جدا
وطبعا لهذه الزلزال هو التاخير في
المداخله التاخير على الاقل في الانقاز هو
شكل هو شكل الكارثه ان الزلزال هو بحد
ذاته كما
يقولون جميع ويتفقون جميع
المحللين
والمختصين بانها
لا يقتل اللي يقتل هو البناء هو الفساد في
البناء وفي الاعمار وفي الاعفاءات هذه
الحصيله ما حصلت فعلا كارثه اجتماعيه
بتقدير هذا نتائجها ستكون
سترتد الى المسؤولين بحد ذاتهم المحليين
كان او
بالحقيقه السلطه بحد ذاته لانه مسؤوليه عن
هذه النتائج يعني نسمع بانه تم القاء
القبض على مقاولين
بمطارات التركيه ولكننا لم نسمع عن توقيف
اي متنفذ او اي مسؤول يعني منصب عالي
بالدوله اتخذ قرار
صح هذا هذه المشكله عزيزتي هذه المشكله
الاساسيه يعني تصورين يعني الان بهذه
الزلزال حسب الادعاءات الان يوصل الى
المئه الف قتيل يعني في هذه الزلزال والان
تجاوز ال35 الف الان تحت الانقاذ اسى
العشرات الالاف بالحقيقه طيب مين المسؤول
عن هذه الامر هل هي فقط هذه مجموعات انقاذ
او التي يعطي الرخص فقط في هذه المساله ام
الحكومه وين كانت فعلا والتشريعات اين هي
التشريعات المعلنه يعني هون السؤال والناس
بدات تتساءل في هذه الامر تصوري الان
القوافل التي تحاول ان تصل بدء تصادر
تصادر من اطراف من مجموعات بالحقيقه من
طرف الحكومه بانه الحكومه بحد ذاتو السلطه
تحتكر بدها حتى تحتكر هذه الامر بانه نحن
عملنا طيب عملته مهما انقذت الان اذا وصل
هذه الاعداد توصل الى 100 الف طيب مين
المسؤول عنها نعم لذلك الان بدون استقالات
بدون محاسبات بالحقيقه على المستوى الاعلى
المركزي لا يمكن بالحقيقه الوصول لاي
نتيجه
سنشاهد معك سيد بركات ومع المشاهدين خريطه
الان
لتوزيع مباني
توكي هي هذه المباني مقاومه للزلازل
نشاهد عده مناطق
بتركيا
وتوسع هذه المناطق وتوزع مباني طوكي حسب
المناطق نلاحظ بانه تحديدا بقهرمان مرعش
هناك 5000
و545 مبنى مشيد حسب انه مقاوم للزلازل
بالمقابل مثلا بغازي عنتاب هنالك 27,000
تقريبا 28
مبنى مقاوم للزلازل طيب على اي اساس سيد
بركات
تعطى رخص
لمبان ان لا تبنى على اساس مقاوم للزلازل
بمنطقه مثلا مثل كهرمان مرعش وهي معروفه
انها على خط زلازل يعني هناك حد ادنى من
المراقبه هناك حد ادنى من الرخص التي تعطى
بمناطق خطيره اصلا
بالحقيقه عزيزتي هذه هو السؤال المهم بانه
هو الفساد والرشاوي المستشري هو اللي
ادى ومن خلال المسؤولين والبروقراطي
الموجوده هي اللي ادتها لهذه النتائج لو
كان فعلا محاسبي لو كان التزام في
القوانين في المبادئ هذه الانشاءات
والمباني والاعمار لمكان هذه النتائج
والماساه التي نعيشها تصوري في انطاكيا في
هاتاي انطاكيا يعني من اكبر المدن
المنكوبه الان يعني في احدى المدن في
ارزين منطقه تابعه لانطاكيا لم تدمر بيتا
واحد لانه هناك لا يوجد بيوت طوابق عاليه
وكل مبنيه على اساس ورئيس البلديه
بالحقيقه هناك انسان
ملتزم بكل هذه الامور وحتى كان يعاقب
وينقذ بانه لا يتهاون نعم شكرا نعم جزيلا
لك اذا نسيت المحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا
على رايك
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
متواعدا الغرب سننهي احتكاركم لشؤون
العالميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سرجال فراف على ان موسكو ستركز على
انهاء ما اسماه بالاحتكار الغربي للشؤون
العالميه كجزء من السياسه الخارجيه
الجديده لروسيا
مفهوم سياساتنا الخارجيه الجديد سيركز على
الحاجه على انهاء احتكار الغرب لتشكيل
اطار الحياه الدوليه الذي لا يجب ان تحدده
في المستقبل مصالحه الانانيه ولكن على
اساس توازن عادل وشامل للمصالح
وبالتزامن اعلن الامين العام لحلف الناتو
يانستول تمبرغ ان وزراء دفاع الحلف اقروا
المفهوم الجديد للتخطيط العسكري مؤكدا ان
هذا المفهوم يضع التهديدات الصينيه
والروسيه والتهديدات الارهابيه في الحسبان
مشيرا الى ان المفهوم يعكس واقعا جديدا
للحلف
وينضم الينا من مقر مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي
في باريس اوليفيي كاديك نائب رئيس لجنه
الشؤون الفرنسيه او الشؤون الخارجيه في
المجلس اهلا بك يعني مفهوم جديد يضعه
للتهديدات واتفاق على زياده انتاج وتصنيع
الذخائر لحساب اوكرانيا هل رؤيه المشرعين
الاوروبيين وحضرتك مشرع
وخاصه المشرعين الفرنسيين تتفق مع الشاشه
في هذا التغيير
نحن نواجه تهديدا
وجودي من جانب روسيا التي تستهدف
النموذجنا النموذج الغربي وهي تستهدف
الديمقراطيه كافه الديمقراطيات هذا بلد
استبدادي يقوده نظام استبدادي على راسها
السيد بوتين الذي يريد ان يستهدف كافه
الديمقراطيه طبعا نحن مستعدون وينبغي ان
ننظم صفوفنا
نريد ان نتعثر بهذه المقاربه الجانبي
بوتين وانما نستعد للاستجابه عند الضروره
كيف تعلق على تصريحات الامين العام لحلف
الناتو مؤخرا التي قال فيها ان الجيش
الاوكراني يستهلك من الاسلحه والذخائر
اكثر مما تنتجه كافه الدول الاوروبيه اي
تحدي يفرضه ذلك ان كان على فرنسا وعلى دول
الاوروبيه
اعتقد ان هذا انذار من اعاده تقييم
وكذلك انتاجنا العسكري الحرب
مره وهي عنيفه وسيد بوتين يطلق الصواريخ
ويرسل ايضا القوات الى اوكرانيا
والاوكرانيا يدافعون بطريقه شجاع وهم
يحتاجون للاسلحه للدفاع عن انفسنا من
العام لانيت وجه انذارا وتحذيرا من اجل
اعاده تقييم قدرتنا الانتاجيه في المجال
العسكري حين يتحدث رئيس الاركان اركان
الفرنسي عن تغيير بمفهوم فرق المشاه وعدم
الاعتماد على يعني الذخائر بقدر الاعتماد
على المسيرات والحرب الالكترونيه ذلك
تغيير جوهري بمفهوم وعمل الجيش
هل يمر هكذا موضوع او هكذا اقتراح وتغيير
عبر المشرعين
[موسيقى]
مما قاله رئيس هيئه الاركان
فهو عبر عن الاحتياجات والوزير وزير
الدفاع سوف يقيم الوضع واذا مكانه هناك
حاجه لتطوير ما ينبغي القيام به عندئذ سوف
ان يطلبوا منا
توفير التمويل لذلك ولكن انا شخصيا لما
تلقى اي معلومات بشان هذا التطور اما
بالنسبه
لاهميه المسيرات في المعارك صحيح نحن
مجندون بشان هذه القضيه التي تحتاج اعاده
النظر في الكثير من الامور وهذا يتطلب
تاقلم مع شكل جديد من المعارك وقد شاهدنا
ذلك في مساحات الصراع مره اخرى يعود
للتاقلم مع اشكال جديده من الصراعات من
بين المعايير التي وضعها الرئيس مانويل
ماكرون كشرط اساسي لارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا الا تؤثر على القدرات الدفاعيه
لفرنسا كيف يمكن ان تؤثر قله هذه
الاسلحه على قدرات الدفاعيه لفرنسا وعلى
الامن القومي الفرنسي
ان رئيس جمهوريه ورئيس الجيوش نريد ان
نتاكد انه في جميع ظروف تستطيع فرنسا
تدافع عن نفسها
اتجاه اي هجوم وبالتالي رئيس الجمهوريه
حريص ان يكون لدى فرنسا الاسلحه الضروريه
للرد على اي غزه
واوكرانيا تواجه عدوانا مباشره على
اراضيها
يمكن لاوكرانيا او لا يجب لاوكرانيا ان
تخسر هذه المعركه يجب ان تنتصر فيها لان
هذه الرساله نوجهها الى روسيا وكل البلدان
التي تريد ان تختفي اثار روسيا يجب احترام
سياده الدول وشعوب وهذا ما لا يفعله
الرئيس بوتين هو يريد ان يرسل قوتي وكانه
جاء من الماضي ليس هذه الطريقه التي تسمح
ببناء مست العالم يجب ان نبني ذلك معا
ونحترم بعضنا البعض
ويجب ان نفرض على الرئيس بوتين احترام
غيره
شكرا ابراهيم لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
المجلس
يوم امس مشاهدينا تحدثنا عن نقصه مخزون
الدول الغربيه لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا ويبدو
ان هذه الدول تحاول اللجوء لمصدر جديد
للدعم صحيفه فاينل تايمز كشفت في تقرير
لها انا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عرضت
على عده دول في امريكا اللاتينيه ان تتبرع
لاوكرانيا بمعداتها العسكريه القديمه
روسيا الصنع على ان تقدم لهم واشنطن اسلحه
متقدمه المقترح الامريكي قبل برفض واسع في
هذه الدول الرد الاقوى جاء من الرئيس
الكولومبي جوستافو باترو الذي قال ان
بلاده لن ترسل اسلحتها لاوكرانيا حتى وان
انتهى بها الامر كخرده في كولومبيا الرئيس
البرازيلي لولا ديسيلفا شدده هو الاخر على
انه لا مصلحه للبرازيل في نقل الذخائر
لاستخدامها في الحرب بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
وشدد على ان العالم يحتاج الى من يريدون
السلام
كلمه لم تستخدم الا قليلا حتى الان خلال
الازمه بحسب دسيلر قبل ذلك عاد المستشار
الالماني اولا
من رحلته الى البرازيل والارجنتين وتشيلي
بعد ان رفض رؤساء هذه الدول طلبا باعاده
بيع ذخيره الدبابات الى بالين كما انتقد
الرئيس المكسيكي
علنا لموافقته على ارسال دبابات لوبارد
الى اوكرانيا قائلا ان برلين تقوم بخطوات
تخالف رغبات معظم الالمان مواقف الكثير من
رؤساء امريكا اللاتينيه تتوافق مع
استطلاعات ابسوس للراي في المنطقه والتي
اظهرت ان نحو 73 بالمئه لا يؤيدون دعم
اوكرانيا وانهم يؤمنون ان بلادهم لا
تستطيع تقديم دعم مالي او عسكري لهذا
البلد
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده لتداعيات كارثه الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا ككل الكوارث لم تخلو هذه الكارثه
من المستغلين وخاصه عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي محتالنا يدعون جمع التبرعات من
اجل المتضررين من الزلزال ويجمعون الكثير
من الاموال على حساب من يبتون في العراء
نقاط سودت كشفت مع الهبه التضامنيه لنجده
المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا رغم
النقاط المضيئه التي حملتها استغلال في
ابشع صوره ومحاوله خداع من يرغبون في
التبرع لضحايا الكارثه الطبيعيه التي قلبت
حياه العشرات لماساه حقيقيه فالكثير من
المحتالين عبر من منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
يزعمون انهم يجمعون تلك الاموال للناجين
الذين تركوا بدون ماوى او تدفئه او ماء
بعد الكارثه التي حلت بهم ولكن بدلا من
مساعده المحتاجين يقوم المحتلون بتحقيق
مكاسب ماديه من خلال تحويل التبرعات بعيدا
عن المؤسسات الخيريه الحقيقيه الى
حساباتهم على تطبيق باي بال ومحافظ
العملات المشفره التي يملكونها فعلى موقع
تويتر انشا محتالون حسابات وهميه تحمل
صورا مؤثره ون الروابط لحسابات على بايبال
لجمع التبرعات ومن اهم الطرق والادوات
التي يستخدمها المحتلون ايضا البث المباشر
على منصات التواصل فتطبيق تيك توك تحصل
على نسبه 70% من عوائد الهدايا الرقميه في
حين نفت الشركه صحه الخبر كما ان حساب
التركي ريليفا الذي لديه واحد وثلاثون
متابعا فقط وانضم الى التويتر من خلال
الترويج للتبرعات عبر باي بال تلقى حتى
الان تبرعات بقيمه 900 دولار امريكي سرقه
اموال المعاناه تاتي فيما الالاف يبيتون
في العراء وسط قساوه البرد وحلمهم الوحيد
الحصول على خيمه ما ودنا السكر
[موسيقى]
محمد
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا عطل اذا يبلغ عنه في عدد من
الدول الدول الشرق الاوسط بتويتر منذ
عشرين دقيقه على الاقل بدبي لازال يعمل
يعني ليس لدينا مشكله تتابعون بعض الفاصل
في عثمانيات تركيا القطارات لا تتحرك وهذا
اقصى ما يحلم به منعانا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال مصدر رئاسيون فرنسي
للعربيه ان ارسال ايران لمسيارات الى
روسيا هو موضع مراقبه دقيق في العاصمه
الاوروبيه وانه سيكون ضمن اجنده النقاش في
مؤتمر ميونخ للامن واوضح المصدر ان هذا
الملف كان احد اسباب حزمه العقوبات
الاوروبيه الاخيره على ايران
هذا ونقل موقع اوكسيوس عن مسؤول اوروبي
قوله ان قرارا يتعلق بالعقوبات على الحرس
الثوري الايراني سيصدر خلال ايام بينما
قالت رئيسه الاوروبيه ارسل منذر لينه ان
المفوضيه تناقش مقترح ادراج سبعه كيانات
ايرانيه على قوائم العقوبات بسبب تزويد
الحرس الثوري لروسيا بالمسيرات
الحرس الثوري الايراني يزود روسيا بمثيرات
شاهد حيث تستخدمها في الاعتداءات على
البنى التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا ولذلك
نقترح ادراج سبعه كيانات ايرانيه في قائمه
العقوبات المتصله بالمعدات ذات الاستخدام
المزدوج هذه الكيانات ستخضع لحظر كامل
يمنعها من تصدير مواد دقيقه الى روسيا
ونحن مستعدون لادراج المزيد من كيانات
ايران والدول الاخرى التي تزود روسيا
بالتكنولوجيا الحساسه
مشاهدينا بالنسبه للعطل الذي تم التبليغ
عنه من مستخدمي الشرق الاوسط يبدو ان
المشكله هي في التغريدات لانه اخر تغريده
على تويتر هي منذ 20 دقيقه اذا تويتر يعني
يمكن الولوج اليه لكن هناك مشكله في
التغريدات نتابع جوزيف بار المسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه الاوروبيه كشف عن مقترح
جديد للعقوبات على ايران يفرض حظرا تاما
على تصدير اي مكونات تفيد المؤسسات
الايرانيه المصنعه للمسيارات
اقتراح اليوم يفرض حظرا تاما على تصدير اي
مكونات لفائده المؤسسات الايرانيه التي
تصنع المسيرات وقد بحثنا يوم امس في
اجتماع حلف الناتو ادله قاطعه على تزويد
ايران لروسيا بالمسيرات
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه ان القوات
الامريكيه الموجوده في سوريا تمكنت من
اسقاط طائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع الثلاثاء
الماضي اثناء اجرائها عمليه استطلاع
لقاعده دوريات في المنطقه ونقلت وسائل
الاعلام ايرانيه عن قائد عسكريا ايراني
قوله ان الطائره الصغيره الحجم يتم
اطلاقها يدويا لاختبارات دفاعات العدو على
حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت نيكي هيلي المندوبه الامريكي
السابقه لدى الامم المتحده ترشحها لخوض
انتخابات الحزب الجمهوري من اجل اختيار
مرشح الانتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه وتعهدت
هيلي بمواجهه من وصفتهم باعداء امريكا في
روسيا والصين وايران داعيه الامريكيين
لتصويت لها
يمكنه قيادتنا على الاطلاق خلال فترته
اجتاح الارهابيون افغانستان وقتلوا جنودنا
هناك وايران تقترب من الحصول على قنبله
نوويه وكوريا الشماليه تطلق تجارب صاروخيه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى وروسيا اطلقت الحرب
الاكبر في اوروبا خلال 75 عاما ونواجه
العدو الاقوى والاكثر تنظيما في التاريخ
لم نعتقد اننا سننظر للسماء لنجد من طادا
تجسس موجها الينا ساكون واضحه للنفوز
بالتحدي في القرن الحادي والعشرين طالما
اعتمدنا على سياسيين من القرن العشرين
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم اود التاكيد على رغبتي
ارمينيا في السلام وتطبيع العلاقات
الكامله مع تركيا التصريح هو لوزير
الخارجيه الارميني ارارات ميرزويان الزائر
لتركيا والذي اكد ايضا تضامن بلاده الكامل
مع انقره في كارثه الزلزال يقدم الوزير
الارميني عرضا اذا لاقامه علاقات
دبلوماسيه غائبه منذ انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام 1991 من الواضح اذا ان
الزلزال مثل ما هدم المباني هدم جدار
الخصومه بين تركيا وجيرانها او على الاقل
تسبب في تصدعه
فيديو اليوم من مقاطعه عثمانيه التركيه
حيث ضاقت الارض بالمشردين من الزلزال فلم
تجد السلطات هناك مفرا من تسكين المئات
منهم في محطه القطارات المحليه وجدها اواء
في المحطه وفي قطاراتها اهم ما يحتاجونه
من غذاء وماء ساخن وامدادات الطاقه والاهم
ان القطار لم يتصدع كمنازلهم فمهما اهتز
سيبقى في مكانه
[موسيقى]
اذا عاد موقع تويتر ويمكنكم الان التغريد
سوره اليوم من هاتايا التركيه تسرد
الموظفه المعنيه برعايه الاطفال قصه قصيره
على صغيره نجت من الزلزال علها تساعدها في
النوم ايا صغيره غدا سنبني لك منزلا جميلا
غير الذي هوى منزلا تغمره الالوان فيه
المرايا في كل ركن كي تمشط شعرك الجميل
فيه خزانات مليئه بالفساتين كي تدور بها
كالفراشه فيه مكان للعب وقطت جميله بذيل
طويل سنبني لك كل هذا بمجرد ان نجد مقاولا
لديه
شكرا جزيلا لكم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
ملفات اخرى يفتحها الزميل صهيب شراير
واخبار الساعه مساء الخير مساء الخير
راويه وعلى راس هذه الملفات المعابر بين
تركيا وسوريا والمعابر داخل سوريا بين
مختلف المناطق حسب الجماعات لايصال
المساعدات للمتضررين جراء الزلزال وتويتر
كما ذكرتي يعود للعمل بعد عطل في الشرق
الاوسط لحوالي نصف ساعه سنبحث مع باحث
تقني اسباب هذا العمر
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]